君たち
sns を使ってますか facebook とか twitter とかいう生主な
ものだと思うんですけれども皆
思ったこと言えてる回僕の課題なんですけど結構なんか twitter とか
facebook って本当の知り合いとかが多いからあんまりね
おれオレはだよ俺の考えなんですけど僕はあんまり目立てるなことを言いたくないん
ですよ
sns でねもし例えばだよ嫌なことがあってクソ
偉大なスルーとか言ったらソロし合ってる人は友達とか知り合い
んなわけじゃないですかイライラするって言ってその人が心配しないわけないじゃない
ですか絶対心配するよ
なって知り合いがさんなんて友達がさイライラするとか困ってたらさ
心配すんじゃ
なんかね尾根おり的にはね俺的にはで友達とか知り合いにあんまり心配させたくない
から俺はねあんまりそういやなこととかもイライラしたことがあってもあんまに sns
ではつぶやかないんです誰も得しないじゃないですか
っていう僕の考えなんですけどもまぁ皆さんはそういう sns どのように使って
いるでしょうか思ったことがバンバンいえなかなかいいんですけどみんなが見ちゃう皆
さんみんな
心配したわけですよボケがそんな悩みが多いわけじゃないですよいつも結構津南ポノス
てるしね
枚なんですけどもう悩みをぶつける場所がない人もいると思うんですよ
いうと思うリアルにそこの君も
ひょっとしたら人に言えないようにあるんじゃないですか浮気不倫友達関係なんかカー
玉悩みとか恋愛とかね
いじめとか仕事とか本当にみんないろいろねー何出ると思うんですよ
q それを友達に言って心配させるのかなぁすごい嫌だって言っても良いと思います
実際そういう皆さんに今回おすすめのアプリを紹介しようと思います
ルーマーというアプリです
英語トルーマーと噂って意味ですマーラーですねまぁ匿名なんですが基本的に解く滅
レートが友達もできないけど匿名ねぇ
つぶやけますよそれに自分でバレずにみんなに自分の悩みを聞いてもらえるっていう
結構気楽な感じの sns です
本音で語れるっていうねトびだけですね投稿に対してのコメントができるんですけど
そのコメントを全部匿名ですすべてが匿名いじめと傘友達関係とかさ
浮気とかそういうのってやっぱり友達に言いにくいわけですよそれを聞いて友だちが
どう思うかってすごく効いなるじゃん立場とか関係とか関係なくで綱をに自分の気持ち
を盗んたちも冴えるっていう
そういうルーマーとアプリがあるんで今回実際に紹介してみようと思います
5ってながらやったけど企業とのタイアップなんだった
駆け込みよ
はいこれですかわいいです
チャックノ口そうですよね内緒なんです
これねっ花火あるちょっ友達が今この下に書いてあるんですけどまぁ18人いますこれ
は友達が書いたってことこれは人気のブーマー
これは人気の投稿ってことですよね友達人気新着検索ハッシュタグをつけることによっ
てマダイのなんかそれをこうみんなで共有一人で行きますね名節不滅0
こういう愚痴を言ったこういう投稿に対して僕たちはコメントができるわけです気合い
送信
大勢いざ匿名男性本当にウトメ何でも本当に思ったほど素直に書いていいんでさん傷
待ってる人も多いと思うんですよそこの君行き詰まってたらさ
こういうテーマでコーバットさ自分のも言っちゃってもいいと思うんだよね
セッシャーとレッツんだって友達をちょっと攻めてみましょうこれは自分の友達の中の
投稿なんですけど台が投稿した勝手のわからないんでを
でもこれ投稿できるのかなん
床したできるハス統合
御礼
かなり入って面
決まったね本音だねこういうのもっともグイグイだしていきたいわけよ
これ友達が来連れていってことですよ痩せたい
ベッドを屋さんきた
練習したし分に彼氏と休みがあったちょっと早いけどバレンタインデーとかどこ行こう
かな
俺の競り合いの中にえ俺の摺合にいるっけ
誰だ誰わかんない女の人ですよでも
期限のいるのが早いんだよ見わかりますよそれは多いのも早いんですからヒゲは20歳
から急に来た目はわかりますよこれは本当に全部抜きましょう
えっ彼氏が by かもしれない見極め方教えてください
a なんかあれだな大変ですねみんなルーマーて噂って意味なんですけどそんな感じ
ですね軽い噂の中に pot 4重いとか本心を乗せてみんながコメントくれるみたい
な
10名な感じです結構
アクチ道
後でもうメッツピアノきてるやねえやめキテルキテルいやーコメント10件起きている
a 叩かれてはぁまぁ気ねーし自分キターやっぱり木目田前世楽しいなら写真見せろよ
イケメンって言う俺の方がイケメンです一番好き期待を路沿いてメイク
みんないいたような嫌がってすわー
ゆるさね僕は心の広い人間なんで
神ばとか冷静にまあ
市民や静まれ静まれって感じでねここは何も返すわね面白いだ鈴木いろんな人が
いろんなものを飛ばしてくる
友達っていうのがね本当に怖いんですよ自分の知り合いの誰かがこれを投稿するという
ことなので本当に今までにないような本心で重ねるようなとてもいいアプリだと思って
おりますはいどうだったでしょうかるーまあまあ友達とか知り合いの花
してるのにそのつぶやきとか投稿が誰かというのが分からないのはまぁいいとこだと
思います facebook とかも完全に自分の名前だから自分がこれをつぶやいて
みんながどう思うかとか考えながら呟くがなくちゃいけないんで
このアプリだったらねまあ友達も知り合いにも見られつつちゃんと本音が話せるって
いうねほんとに砂にコミュニケーションできるものってなんか
泣かないですよぜひ人に言えないこととかあったら
ルーマーを使ってみてくださいこうゆうちゃんと思ったことが言えてみんなの阿蘇
ヴァイスがもらえるアプリがたくさんの人を救うのかも知れませんねまぁ
複雑な世の中なので